Tyrus the man with no equal is dropping
a sequel he wowed us before and now he's
given us more tyrus's new book enough
said came out today and it sure to be
another runaway best seller joining us
to discuss is the man himself author
comedian and former NWA world
champion
pirat sit down everybody sit down sit
down so tyus congrats I hope this is as
huge as the first one how much do you
talk about me in this new
book okay before we start Greg because I
want I want this show to air yeah the
whole Barack Obama Morgan Freeman thing
I called the black caucus you're good
you've been approved so you're good so
that's one thing
yes yes I am released that's a lot of
Applause black people in the audience
tonight yes all right and it's entirely
black they knew you were
here oh yes actually one half is black
and the other half is
white
yeah sweet you so Tom will stay
yes so you tackle a lot of subjects
immigration BLM pronouns what will
people be most surprised to hear read
about uh well first probably my uh
amazing blurb from uh uh don't not from
sure Greg from a Greg Gutfeld oh yes so
uh Greg wrote the blurb yes uh which was
I appreciate it thank you very much for
that boss uh you know it's uh we're
going we're punching people in the mouth
we're and we're just speaking on a bash
we got to say uh the address the issues
in the room from a conservative
perspective and from a grown ass man
perspective so uh we're we uh the first
book was about me and the the second
book is about everybody else yeah you
know what's I think why you were so
popular is that you the grown ass man
part and not because of size but nobody
hears any of that anymore it's all like
beta
male like self-help crap is there
anything you shi away
from no uh and the funny thing was a few
times Post Hill was like are you sure
about this probably the most
controversial thing I wrote about was
abortion through a man's perspective and
uh you know because and that's one of
those things because they never really
ask us what we feel about it and uh or
even just trying to understand or cuz if
you look at it through a man's
perspective we're trying to understand
the woman's perspective because it can
be very confusing for us at times
because we don't operate by the same
rules where whenever we go through a
situation A man is expected to accept it
be accountable for it and keep and
continue to take care of it so uh
whereas a woman's perspective is a
little bit different so that was the one
they were a little worried about but
again I just feel like a man doesn't
have a right to tell a woman what to do
with her body but when it comes to
accountability I think we can ask some
questions sometimes very good you also
have a chapter on bullying what are you
hoping other parents take away from your
advice uh one that we get back to um
supporting our schools and our teachers
and and vice versa and stop giving our
kids uh what's the word I'm looking
before stop giving them lessons from
Criminal movies like stop telling your
kids snitches get stitches okay like my
son told me when I said that he said Dad
that's something a criminal says so we
need to start getting back to like
parenting and uh confronting the bully
because the best way to stop a bully is
to tell on him because after a while
they'll get tired of messing with you
this whole don't tell anybody thing keep
it to yourself uh not you know you got
to talk about it you got to post it be
that tattletail because tattletails have
less bruises M that's what I tell those
kids I beat
up that's what I always say all right I
we got one time for one more question
the book is called enough said everybody
has to buy it does that mean that's your
last book what are you g to do how can
you do another book if this is called
enough
said well then I just come back with
what it
is there you go all
right thank you Greg everybody go out
and buy his book make it to number one
Tyrus good to see you as always see you
soon I hope Happy Thanksgiving America
all right up next Will O zic ruins mom's
goal of force feeding green bean
casserole hey Sean Hann here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else